I don't know what I'm doing Hey
yeah people hello I'm in my new favorite
jumper which has a lot of food on it I
have my purple hair thank you
it's faded a lot in the last few days so
this is pretty much the original color
here and this is what most of it is now
kind of silvery um I'm good I filmed a
couple of videos today so they're
hopefully going up in the next couple of
weeks um I thought I'd reuse all my
makeup all right so our first question
can I please talk about the importance
of home care um I'm not really a an
expert in like clinical care I guess but
I've been told that home carriers may be
about 20% or one-third according to what
they think um I don't know I think
there's a lot to be said for consistent
routine for sure um I do have purple
browsers yes I thought it was only
natural if I've got purple hair I should
have purple brows as well um yes a home
care pretty pretty important I think
especially sunscreen hello hi spicy
brown sugar I like your name um waiting
Astro playing actives there is a really
firm research on this um I think a lot
of people think that waiting will help
with like not disturbing the ph
afterwards and also I guess maybe
keeping more of the active ingredient on
your skin hey Mel um I think that's
where it comes from there's no real
research
so I reckon what you should probably do
is just like put it on and wait and then
maybe after a week try not putting it on
and not well putting it on and not
waiting and let's see if it makes a
difference and yeah I think it's just
really trial and error um alcohol um so
you guys might know kind of Stephen who
is a cosmetic chemist and he also does
lots of skincare based science on
Instagram and on his blog as well we've
actually recorded a podcast on alcohol
and skin my friend Rose has kindly
edited it for us um and that should be
coming out soon ish cuz she's done a
really good job we're just trying to
find intro music so if anyone has
suggestions for intro music please send
them our way and yeah so we'll try to
get that up ASAP um how do I feel about
micro needling um I haven't really
looked that much into micro needling
it's been on my research list for ages I
will definitely get around to it because
I've tried it a little bit on my own
skin already um yeah I think if it's
done right it seems pretty promising um
is vitamin C still active as an
antioxidant if it's oxidized
um again that's a bit of a mixed bag it
looks like at least it isn't harmful but
whether or not it's active there is one
company that I know of who have
supposedly got data saying that the
oxidized version does work on skin or at
least it's beneficial maybe in a
different way um yeah no one knows but
yeah um what vitamin C serum would I
recommend that you can buy in Australia
well I personally really like DIY serum
so DIY serum you get some l-ascorbic
acid from somewhere like I heard I have
a recipe on my blog you pretty much just
mix it with water and baking powder no
baking soda sorry you mix it until it's
the right pH and then you just apply to
your
skin you chuck it out after about a week
whole chair
because it's too oxidized um yeah it
doesn't really need a preservative
because the pH is low enough that it
pretty much is sort of like vinegar it
will be acidic enough that microbes just
won't grow um and also you're chucking
it out in two weeks anyway and I found
that that DIY serum actually works the
best and you can make that anywhere um
in terms of ready-made ones there's one
by suta khals that's really good and
that's I think they're based in Perth
which is in Australia their recipe is
pretty much the same as well it sort of
got the cd4 really combo um there's also
skin date skin diva skin daiba
that i reviewed a bit earlier and that's
also really really inexpensive
I think the shipping might take a while
to Australia though yeah all right I'm
just gonna look through this phone to
try to scroll back up and find some
questions that might have been asked
earlier I really should have set this up
earlier um if it's worth getting a jaffa
lean I not actually sure I haven't
really looked into all the different
rationale its yet and again that's
another thing that's been on my to post
list
um I don't if I believe from memory a
Japanese best for acne and treating acne
scars I think Stevens posted about how
you can use it to treat a tropic
atrophic acne scars um I think for a
dappling the anti-aging benefits aren't
really well studied unlike things like
treasure Nolan so yeah if you if you're
trying to treat acne I think it's a
really good choice um brightening
pigmentation I have a video on
brightening pigmentation and in it I
talk about all my favorite active
ingredients I think the best things are
probably sunscreen so sunscreen that's
got good UVA protection I think is
really really important both in my
experience in like in the literature as
well vitamin C and a
Chay's can help as well and my favorite
of those is lactic acid um facial
massage I have mixed feelings about
facial massage on one hand I think
temporarily it's really good for making
your face look better because it pushes
up the lymph but I think in the long run
it's possible that you might be
traumatizing your skin so when you get
older
one thing that tends to happen is that
some of your laser skin tend to get more
fragile and so they tend to like get a
bit unstuck and so if you're in that
category like tugging and pulling at
your skin might not be so good so I have
mixed feelings on it um I think if you
go gently it should be fine
um fading acne scars again I have a
video on that and yeah it's the if
you're talking about post inflammatory
hyperpigmentation it's the same things
as fading pigmentation so sunscreen
vitamin C a chase there's a few other
things as well like licorice there's an
ingredient in licorice that starts with
G and I can't remember how to pronounce
it but it's like glitter is eight or
something um yeah there's a few other
things that aren't coming to my head
right now but yeah it's in the videos of
my um my opinion on polyethylene I don't
have a strong opinion on polyethylene I
don't really know that much about how
well it decomposes and what the effects
in the environment are um in terms of
plastic microbeads they're not great but
compared to things like synthetic fibers
it isn't a huge issue there was actually
recently a paper on that that got
retracted which was about how it
accumulated in fish but there is other
bad evidence as well or other evidence
that it's bad for fish so it's still not
like completely fine but I think just
try to cut down on it um
yeah in terms of the matting cleanses
I'm not sure and I don't know how much
research there is on that unfortunately
um can you lay a chemical sunscreens
with the new filters with mineral
zinc oxide based ones layering
sunscreens it's always a little [ __ ]
question 'l imeem layering anything on
top of sunscreen it's always going to be
a little bit shaky sorry because um the
way that sunscreens are tested are just
in a layer on your skin they put it on
the skin usually with like like a glove
basically a glove they put the right
amount and then they shine light on it
and that's the only way it's tested they
don't put things on it over it under it
yeah so there's no guarantee that if you
put something on top of or under the
sunscreen that will still work but from
all the evidence all the real-world
studies it looks like it does yeah so in
terms of layering sunscreens I think it
in most cases it shouldn't be that much
different from layering other products
over it um yeah so layering products
over it it's gonna remove a bit of the
underneath layer so it could potentially
not work as well um but I think
generally it shouldn't be an issue
yeah um thoughts on seven-layer method
um I haven't personally tried it if you
have more water on your skin it does
tend to be more permeable so I think if
you have easily irritated skin if you
have sensitive skin maybe seven layers
might irritate your skin more than
having a few less layers plus you're
touching it and like you might be like
disturbing your skin a bit as well um I
think also it might just be a little bit
of a waste of money if you're if your
tone is expensive if you can afford it
then of course yeah go ahead and try it
um yeah I think there are more efficient
ways of getting the same ingredients on
your skin um all right what other things
are there oh I can't scroll up that far
oh dear
hmmm best special without causing
breakouts um the things that cause
breakouts it's different for everyone
so far I've never broken up with any
cleansing oil so I think it's really a
case of tracking what breaks out your
skin and trying to get trying to get a
good guess of what mailmen I'll break
out your skin personally yeah so it
really depends on your skin I personally
use just she Amira cleansing all I've
used simple cleansing oil I've recently
started using Frank cleansing oil as
well and Jurlique as well and none of
them have broken out my skin but yeah I
know a lot of people break up from oils
I'm not one of them so yeah it depends
on your skin I will definitely save this
live and I will post it probably on both
I J TV and on YouTube um I think I can't
really scroll back after the really
early ones on this second phone
unfortunately so if you sent me a
question at the very beginning maybe
send it again um is it safe to use
cleansing oil if you have acne yeah
again it depends on your skin but
generally there isn't like a there isn't
like a set don't use it sort of thing um
Sun cream for oily skin for my oily skin
I like the ultra Souter cause one I like
the can make mermaid gel although I
think it is a little bit light so my
shift around if your skin is quite oily
and if you're sweaty as well um I
personally don't really like using
mineral filters so things like zinc
oxide and titanium dioxide because my
skin is it looks quite light here but um
it's quiet yellow and so if I have a
light lighter thing here and a darker
thing here generally I'm really bad I
put sunscreen mostly on my face and I
tend to ignore my neck a little bit so
it's a little bit darker so if I put a
white thing on my face it gets like the
contrast gets even worse so I try to
avoid zinc oxide plus I don't like the
texture but the best one I've tried that
is a physical filter is your physical
filter sorry Stephen
I know it's kind of Stephen gets really
really upset about this well not I say
he just gets a really salty um some
sense so the son sense one has been the
most calm to one so far um
oh yeah other ones other oily skin
sunscreens I like I'm it's quite annoyed
because in Australia we get a lot of
different sunscreens from the rest of
the world so most of the ones I've been
trying our Australian so I also like the
natio one which is called daily defense
there's a mecca one that I quite like I
think it's the SPF 50 plus to save face
I've also been trying the coals and the
wool west ones Coles and Woolworths I
like the supermarkets that everyone goes
to they're apparently slightly evil but
they do have sunscreens and the wool
this one actually has zinc oxide and I
think it was Tino saw best so I was
actually really impressed by the fact
that they put in a Tino salt which is
one of the newer filters which is a bit
more expensive into their sunscreen and
that one was actually quite nice as well
I really want to try more international
sunscreens though I've gotten so many
recommendations I just haven't had the
time and money to try it yet um oh yeah
so polyethylene I don't know if it's
fine unfortunately um I I would suspect
that it's not great
do you need as much sunscreen for darker
skin depends on what you're trying to do
if you're just trying to prevent skin
cancer then it's you can probably use a
bit less it's a bit hard to say so there
are studies that show that if you use
less sunscreen you just get less SPF
protection but there's also people who
are scientists who suggests that if you
use less sunscreen what happens is
because your skin is really bumpy if you
don't use enough sunscreen you might not
fill up like the valleys and so the tops
of your skin might not get anywhere near
enough protection and so those bits
might be more prone to cancer so it's
always safest to use two milligrams per
centimeter squared but doston does tend
to get cancer a bit less but on the
other hand darker skin they tend to
catch cancer and darkest skin later so
it tends to be a bit more serious so
it's up to you there's no hard and fast
rules on how much sunscreen you need to
use and stuff like that um yeah it
depends how paranoid you are depends if
you're trying to fade hyperpigmentation
as well um um serum under eye area um
generally yeah yeah no there's no like
massive reason why you can't there's a
risk of millia which is the little
they're these little like clogged bits
that are really hard to get rid of I
personally get quite a few sometimes and
digging them out is probably not
something I should be doing at home um
yeah so if you try it and you don't get
milea then yeah and if you don't get
irritation as well that area also tends
to cause irritation um it's a safe to
only use micellar water as the first
cleanser or do you have to use oil
cleanser true after that um depends on
what you've got on your skin so I think
one of the things that people tend to
forget about skin is skin isn't just
like a flat layer that you can
completely clean skin the structure of
skin is there's lots and lots of little
cells so Kurt Cochino sites they're like
little cells
I've got one let me dig him out this guy
alright so you have these little carrot
in the sights and they're kind of like
flattened bricks Oh little rectangle
well hexagonal brick and then in between
them you have all this oil so it's
almost like they used to call it like a
brick brick and morter sort of structure
except it's all really flexi and so
there's actually oil in between the
cells and it's meant to be there
it's called intracellular lipids and so
if you have that stuff like when you're
cleaning your skin you generally want to
not clean it that well because that
stuff's important it sticks all these
cells together if you wash it too much
then all these cells start like flaking
off and going here knows where well down
the sink um and that's how you get flaky
dry skin yeah props yeah yeah I can
claim it back in tax shouldn't have said
that shouldn't have said that I'm right
using it okay um yeah so so you don't
really want to wash all that off there's
also the layer of sebum on top as well
which is part of what's called the oh
crap what's the acid thing as the mantle
that's it the acid mantle on top and so
all of that's really important in
keeping your whole skin intact and
protecting it from things like from like
microbes from from evaporating water so
from water getting out from other things
going in like irritants and so if you
just wash your skin too much you disturb
this layer a lot and then stuff leave so
you so in terms of like how well you
need to clean um you don't really need
to like clean everything off your skin
what probably happens during the day is
your moisturizers your makeup all of
that some of that sinks into that layer
and mixes with the stuff and so like
getting it out you don't want you don't
really want to get it up because it's
got like if stuff you like and it's
probably fine in there it's probably not
that much in there um so in terms of
whether or not it's enough cleanser I
guess it's really a matter of checking
if you'd break out afterwards if you
break out because you've got makeup left
on your skin then you need a stronger
cleanser
another thing I like to do is I like to
check if like the surface stuff is gone
so I get a cotton pad I wet it with
toner and then I wipe it over my skin
and if I see that it's got its makeup
colored or if it's got a bit of judgment
then I know I want to cleanse a little
bit more but you don't really need to be
like squeaky clean you don't need to be
worried about getting every last trace
of sunscreen or makeup off it's probably
fine on there um yes so lazy should
check out ingredients I used to be like
that as well but now that I've read it
enough um I find that I kind of know
what all the words are most of the time
sometimes that still stuff I need to
check I need to look up I'm sure that
that's the case for like everyone except
maybe like because medicare's who have
done tons and tons of formulation um
but yeah after a while you get used to
the more common ingredients and it won't
be so hard I promise favorite anti-aging
skin care product apart from sunscreen
um try to know and I think threatenin
definitely has the most evidence behind
it and I've only just started using it
but I already see that these bits just
look really really good I guess um it
still looks like skin which is nice but
it does look really like I think the
word that people tend to use is like
luminous so I put a bit of highlighter
on then it's just like poo um yes I
treasure knowing is my current favorite
but it does tend to dry out your skin a
whole bunch and again I'm planning to do
a video on how I started on treasure
Nolan and all the tips I have yeah it's
it's an it's on the list
yeah just time um best ingredients to
tackle lines under the eye probably all
the anti-aging ones sunscreen threatenin
also if your skin is dehydrated or dry
it tends to wrinkle up a bit more so
maybe moisturizer so try that as well
yeah does light therapy work on acne
Neutrogena release and mask and a stick
thing I have the mask thing I still
haven't gotten around to using it um
just light therapy work the evidence
looks like it's like a bit mixed um the
thing about light is there's tons of
tons of wavelengths that goes from like
400 nanometers which is purple to 700
nanometers and that's just
of all light so there's been blue light
therapy which mostly kills bacteria
there's been red light therapy which i
think is meant to be regenerative so in
terms of does light work it really
depends on which wavelengths the other
thing is a lot of different um a lot of
different instruments they get they use
different amounts of light so they use
different wavelengths but they also tend
to use like a range of wavelengths and
so it's really hard to look at the
evidence and compare different studies
or read a study and then compare that to
whatever machine you're using the safest
thing is to find a study that's on the
exact machine that your dermatologist
has yeah so it's kind of hard to say and
I am planning to work on her so not as
well yeah but it can work I think
essential oils and skin care good or bad
um depends on the oil so tea tree oil
can be antibacterial if it's diluted
they do tend to be irritating and they
can be allergenic as well so a lot of
people are allergic to them if your skin
isn't sensitive to them then it's
probably fine um yeah um do I avoid
silicone and SLS when choosing hair
shampoo um
I've recently started avoiding SLS
because my scalp does tend to be a bit
dry and I'm starting to think well I
used to because my scalp is pretty oily
I tend to get oily roots and so I really
liked using harsh shampoos but then I
thought about it a bit more and I'm like
I would never use SLS on well I tend not
to use SLS on my face and you know I
used to I think it's probably still fine
but my skin is really dehydration prone
so SLS tends to leave it really
dehydrated and even using tons of
glycerin doesn't really help with that
so I started thinking if I'm not using
it on my skin but I'm using on my scalp
maybe that's why my scalp is tight and
itchy like my face used to be when I
didn't know how to look after my
dehydrated skin
so I started avoiding SLS because of
that and I found that my
now has slowly adjusted to it yeah so I
still don't use that because I don't
want to dehydrate a scalp in terms of
what it does to hair I haven't looked
into that that much for silicones um at
the moment I've been trying to avoid it
because with my hair when I got it
bleached
they used olaplex on it to make sure it
didn't break off which is great so
underneath the purple it's actually like
white white um and so I've got the
olaplex 3 treatment which is meant to
repair the bonds in hair I have a video
on all effects coming out I finished
filming it today
thank you cosmic Lotus leader um yeah so
because I'm using that treatment it
needs to get into the hair and silicones
tend to form a layer over the the hair
so I'm trying to avoid using silicones
as much as possible so that the olaplex
has a chance to think in personally um I
found that using silicones I think it
depends on your hair a lot so there's a
shampoo that I am that works really well
on my hand I know it works really well
on other people's hair and it's the Dove
rich repair I think some repair
something like that and it's got the
condition has silicones in it but it
tends to be a bit light so it doesn't
feel like it's like a coating over
dehydrated or dry hair um and so my
sister for example uses it every time
she conditions her hair and her hair is
gorgeous and long and strong and
undamaged and I am super jealous so I
think it can work for some people
doesn't work Father's depends on the
formula um getting out of a skincare
right when you stopped everything I want
to get back into it so um is it like a
more of an emotional ride or is it like
your skin just doesn't like things I
guess um antioxidants that oxidize on
your face harmful because they form free
radicals
I'm not really so as your oxidants tend
not to form free radicals which is why
they're anti oxidants um yeah they like
most things do like to form free
radicals antioxidants
on the lower end of the scheme yeah um
my opinion on drunk elephant I'm going
to review them I saw that carolyn herons
recently reviewed them as well and I
kind of agree with her love the products
most of the products are great maybe a
little bit overpriced marketing blog um
very oily nose area when moisturizing my
skin I look like a piece of pork oh I'm
sorry
um I think really check out my my video
on oily skin tips that might help and I
think the main things are check if your
skin is dehydrated um if you fix the
dehydration then it sinks and I find
that products sink and just getting more
easily and you end up looking less oily
overall um cleansing oils recommended
for dry skin oils attractive awesome can
dry out skin um almost kind of trapped
oils but yeah I guess oils oils attract
oils yeah okay
oils attract oils but oils also repel
water so when you put the oil on your
skin and you just have like plain old
let's say you just put like sunflower
oil on your skin and you try to wash
that off with water the water won't wash
it off because there's nothing to help
the water combined with the oil and pull
it off so cleansing oils cleansing oils
what they have is oil plus a surfactant
so the surfactant is sort of like oil
and polar stuff all-in-one so it's like
an end that likes oil and an end that
likes water which is why I can pull off
some of the oil so the oil a bit the oil
end holds on to the oil the water end
goes away um normal cleansers have
surfactant with maybe no all or a tiny
bit of oil compared to cleansing oils
and so overall cleansing oils tend
should clear leave more oil in your skin
if that makes sense hopefully all
cleansing on dry sensitive skin um
depends on the oil cleanser depends on
the cleanser but generally I think
it's okay um should you wear sunscreen
on a long flight ah depends on what you
what your skin care goals are um
generally I think I personally do so I
treat it just like if I'm if I'm having
a day next to a window um but if you
think about it in the grand scheme of
things if you're wearing daily sunscreen
having a bit more UV when you're up in
the air where there's more UV having a
few hours of that probably isn't a
massive deal on the green great scheme
of things yeah oh yay crimson and clover
loves the daily defense excellent
um coffee peptides are they really that
great what does the research say about
them I need to look that up again I have
I can't remember exactly that much about
it but I think I wrote about it in the
review I did of Ni OD um hormonal
pigmentation so is that things like
melasma I think most of the time if it's
like really stubborn pigmentation that's
out of the norm so not like post
inflammatory I think your best bet is to
see a dermatologist about that also do
what